[Musique]
les représentants du conseil
départemental des jeunes organise dans
l'hémicycle de la collectivité un grand
débat sur comment répondre aux enjeux
climatiques de demain et la mentalité
aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup oui on va
utiliser les énergies renouvelables et
tout ira bien mais il a tout d'abord il
faut réduire sa consommation
d'électricité
beaucoup de conseillers départementaux
jeunes avaient des questions par rapport
à la juridiction par exemple sur les
sanctions si par exemple on
on trie pas de déchets
les questions sont directement posée à
des experts invités lors de ce débat les
représentants de la direction de
l'environnement de l'aménagement et du
logement des avocats des scientifiques
évoquent des pistes de réflexion pour
mieux comprendre et savoir comment
changer on a échangé avec les jeunes en
disant qu'il fallait concevoir les
nouveaux bâtiments en regardant en fait
la conception des maisons créoles de
temps le temps lontan qu'il fallait
replanter les arbres parce que ça c'est
vraiment quelque chose de très important
l'art vous permet de gagner 6 degrés sur
la température d'air donc revégétaliser
en replantant des arbres autour des
bâtiments pour créer de l'air frais
autour des bâtiments et puis il faut que
les bâtiments ressemble un petit peu à
la sensation qu'on a quand même tourné
sous un arbre justement s'il faut que le
bâtiment soit un système ouvert ouvert
au climat et qui soit pour qu'ils
protègent ses occupants du soleil nous
avons travaillé déjà avec dans les
collèges noms sont des concours
embellissement des collèges nos gaspille
pour la lutte contre le gaspillage
alimentaire on a aussi
sa situation la maîtrise des énergies
donc les jeunes ce n'est le département
sensibilise régulièrement à travers ces
concours à travers sept revers d'autres
d'autres activités comme le plan un
million d'arbres aussi qui passe aussi
par les collèges qui qui
qui fait en sorte que nos jeunes soient
soient touchés par ce qui va faire la
réunion de demain une délégation de
quatre jeunes du cdj se rendra en
novembre prochain à l'assemblée
nationale pour présenter des projets et
les pistes de réflexions issues de ce
grand débat lors de la journée des
droits de l'enfant
[Musique]